et on part à présent à la chasse aux
fausses infos
un fois intox avec Antoine fenaud
aujourd'hui Antoine bonjour Raphaël au
menu un nouvel exemple de propagande
russe oui absolument et vous allez le
voir une propagande russe qui vient du
crâne très précisément et autour d'une
vidéo que je vais vous montrer
immédiatement cette vidéo elle émane du
compte du compte lui-même de la
ministère de la Défense russe qu'est-ce
qu'on y voit une opération militaire
vous le voyez ici un hélicoptère un
hélicoptère d'asso russe les missiles
les pilotes qui se préparent ils
décollent et on va aller voir un petit
peu plus tard vous allez le voir il
survole un champ et ensuite une zone
côtière voilà ici et ils vont ensuite
cibler ce que vous voyez ici ils vont
tirer une salve de missile dessus que
cette vidéo a été publiée sur le compte
télégram du ministère de la Défense
russe dont je vous propose ici une
capture d'écran là ce sont les vidéos
mais je ne peux pas les afficher petit
souci technique car elles sont un peu
trop lourdes ce compte là ici il affirme
que cet hélicoptère donc a mené un
assaut contre une destruction il a
construit une barge de débarquement de
l'armée ukrainienne la vidéo elle a été
elle aurait été tournée le 14 septembre
2022 et naturellement elle a été
largement relayée notamment sur des
contacts un site de streaming russe elle
a accumulé plus de 160 000 vues mais là
où c'est plus intéressant c'est là
également été reprise sur Twitter
notamment par ce compte ici vous le
voyez qui propose donc le même récit que
le ministère de la Défense russe ainsi
que la vidéo c'est également été le cas
en français sur facebook cette fois là
encore on retrouve la même le même le la
même vidéo de l'hélicoptère et le même
récit qu'est-ce que nous dise exactement
ce tweet vous le voyez ils disent que ça
la barge elle transportait des troupes
de nico-paul a energoda et ça vous allez
le voir Raphaël ça va nous intéresser
par la suite
et problème c'est faux et oui
naturellement sinon je ne serai pas là
devant vous pour vous en parler vous
vous en doutez bien et pour se rendre
compte et bien nous à un faux intox
qu'on a fait et bien c'est qu'on a
géolocalisé la vidéo et qu'on s'est
servi des indications qu'on a vu je vous
ai montré le petit tweet qui nous disait
que ça avait été donc tourné entre Nico
Paul et energoda voici une capture
d'écran Google Maps exactement de la
localisation qui se trouve ici vous vous
apercevez nicopole ici au milieu c'est
le fleuve le nièpre et ici c'est cette
petite péninsule regardez-la bien elle
va nous intéresser là aussi j'ai vous
avez proposé quelques captures d'écran
pour vous rendre compte on va recouper
ça avec la vidéo qu'on retrouve bien les
mêmes éléments pour vous en rendre
compte déjà je zoom un petit peu sur la
petite péninsule que je vous montrais
pour vous montrer la cible de la
soi-disant cible de l'armée russe c'est
vous voyez cette petite péninsule là et
c'est ce petit ce petit objet soi-disant
présenté donc comme une barge de
débarquement de
ukrainienne qui va nous intéresser je
vous mets une petite vidéo un peu une
petite capture un peu plus grande vous
voyez c'est cette ce petit objet immergé
exactement de quoi il s'agit déjà on va
retrouver je vais vous montrer que cette
vidéo a bien été tournée à cet endroit
là voici une capture de la vidéo
proposée par les forces qu'est ce que
vous apercevez ici le viseur de
l'hélicoptère naturellement et là trois
petits décochers sur la terre un deux et
trois et trois décocher qu'on va
retrouver un peu plus long ici sur notre
péninsule 1 2 et 3 vous apercevez ici en
fait l'hélicoptère va suivre cette
direction se diriger vers ici et cet
endroit là et là où ça devient
intéressant c'est qu'en fait ce n'est
pas du tout une barge de débarquement de
l'armée ukrainienne il s'agit en réalité
d'un ouvrage bien différent je voulais
le montrer ici donc là voici une capture
terminale du viseur de l'hélicoptère
vous voyez ici ce qui apparaît donc
soi-disant présenté comme la barge de
débarquement à droite et ici le viseur
de l'hélicoptère sauf qu'en réalité bien
Raphaël c'est la pile d'un ancien pont
absolument un ancien pont qui a été
construit pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale par les nazis dans cette région
transporter des troupes à travers ce sur
le fleuve niépre qui a été détruit peu
après dans les années 1950 et il faut
s'en rendre compte il est il suffit
d'aller sur ce site que vous apercevez
wiki mapia c'est un site très utile qui
regroupe tous les ouvrages
infrastructures dans le monde rien que
ça et vous pouvez les retrouver par
géolocalisation et donc c'est ce on
retrouve ici vous voyez la petite
péninsule avec le petit le petit pont au
milieu de la mer avec une photo et vous
allez la voir cette photo et bien on se
rend compte que c'est exactement la même
chose je vais vous la mettre juste à
côté c'est la photo que j'ai prise sur
le site vous le voyez sinon qu'on
reconnaît les anciennes piles d'un pont
en béton et ici vous voyez il s'agit
exactement de la même chose conclusion
tir de missile ça c'est sûr de l'armée
russe mais une visait pas du tout une
barge de débarquement de la de l'armée
ukrainienne mais visiblement les piles
d'un pont c'est donc une opération de
propagande vous l'avez compris et oui
merci Antoine pour cette recherche un
cartable à la pluie et bien sûr avec ses
photos c'est la fin d'un fond intox on
se retrouve dans 4 minutes pour un
nouveau journal